ten years after construction began
water is slowly beginning to rise in
ethiopia's flagship infrastructure
project
the grand renaissance dam which is built
on the blue nile
is set to power a landlocked country of
115 million people
more than half of whom are off the grid
but as ethiopia prepares for the second
phase of filling next month
countries downstream are once again
protesting
but ethiopian officials insist their
plan is not
unilateral three countries have agreed
on the schedule of feeling
let's say they have reached consensus
you know there are scientists
15 of them five from each of the
countries
in 2019 design formulated a filling
schedule
we're just following that feeling
scheduled this is not
unilaterally developed by ethiopia it's
developed by the three countries
experts of the three countries and you
find that schedule in the draft
agreements of sudan
in the draft agreement of egypt and then
draft agreement
in all documents it is there egyptian
and sudanese officials say
that agreement was never signed and
therefore not
legally binding cairo and khartoum have
called for the united states
the united nations and the european
union to help reach a legally binding
deal
after an african union-mediated process
failed to reach an agreement
the deal will spell how the dam is
operated and filled
based on international law and norms
governing cross border rivers
egypt relies on the nile for more than
90 percent of its water supplies
in march egypt's president abdel fattah
al-sisi warned his country's share of
the nile waters was untouchable
and that there will be instability in
the region if ethiopia fills the
reservoir
without an international agreement
ethiopia says the 5
billion dam is essential and that the
vast majority of its population
lacks electricity ethiopia is in
darkness you know 60 percent of
ethiopians do not have access to
electricity
and those who have access to electricity
is a in a
very small distribution with a very
small power that goes to each house
and ethiopia is uh really very much
in need of developing the country
industrialization
you know urban development and bringing
electricity to
rural cities and areas so that you know
this power will be uh you know
instrument
of supporting agro processing
you know other development needs addis
ababa say security at the dam has been
stepped up and the air force is actively
protecting the airspace over it
the announcement follows recent military
exercises by egyptian and sudanese
forces egypt has also signed military
cooperation pacts
with ethiopia's neighbours kenya and
djibouti
the row over ethiopia's dam has security
implications
for the entire region ethiopia accuses
sudan and
egypt of dragging their feet constantly
over the issue of
filling up the dam something it says
both countries knew
would be inevitable one day mohammed
al-jazeera
you